>> I think and believe that the abstention
of Barack Obama will influence the results
of all the work we are doing towards the [inaudible]
situation. The US is a very important player
in this area because it's a country that really
has a lot to give to the world and it's a
country where we look always when we need
to solve the problems that we have. So I think
that the Obama administration has a big contribution
to give to all of us in terms of this situation.
But I also think that we need to give them
time. They need to settle, to analyze the
situation because my prospective does not
look only to the short term. Only to the mandate
that they have with the country. They should
look in terms of long term vision because
their responsibility does not end with the
mandate that they have now. Their responsibilities
could seed, to plan for the future because
some of the results will be seen only some
years from now. Because we should not ask
them to have any of the results. It is not
possible. The situation is very difficult.
They inherit a very difficult situation in
terms of financing, special financing situation,
demonstration. So we need to understand and
we need to believe and to help really to achieve
the results we are foreseeing for our caucus.